This is a
video
for
the
audience.
It is
a
video
that
is
made
for
the
audience.
This is
a
video
that
is
made
for
the
audience.
This video
is
a
video
that
is
for
by
a
This is
video
for
audience.
It is
a
video
that
Cut boy back from the voice box somehow, I ask you to be...
Okay, any other announcements?
Uh-uh.
You sure?
Yeah.
Okay, um, continue with this movie.
Oh, wait a minute.
Amanda has something to show us.
Do your special feature, gymnastics feature.
Pick one at random and come do it.
Here we go.
We're running out of time here.
Come on, time, time, time.
That was cool with that little slide at the end.
Okay, let's do this movie, the 14th.
300 channels and still nothing on.
Is that Stacy?
Huh, get up before she hurts herself.
Are you okay, Stacy?
I hope that didn't spill on the carpet.
Man, that painting looks real good right there.
Yeah.
I painted that.
Cook it?
Actually, Doc Shearer did.
Mm-hmm.
Because I'm more.
Okay.
Gives me more.
Were they downstairs and...
You said Shearer probably did it for kids?
No.
You wore that back in the Power King days.
Turn on this lamp.
I like this.
You want to turn this bulb on?
What?
No, it's okay.
I like the bubble lamp because...
When the kids come up, do you want to do story time?
Oh, yeah.
I love story time.
But right now, let's make some snacks.
And guess what song I'm going to do.
And guess what story I'm going to do.
What?
Magic Pants.
King of Shorts.
Takanuba needs more repairs on his Esanui.
You know what?
Whenever he lands somewhere, he, like, jumps off right before he hits the ground and ends up exploding and everything.
Mm-hmm.
Hitting walls and stuff.
And he runs it into stuff to break it open.
And Doc Shearer sits in the front of it.
Let's make some snacks and blow the kids up.
Okay.
Because they don't usually come up like...
When it's story time.
I mean...
First up, let's put some of these peanut butter chips.
I'm going to put it on this.
There's the mint ones.
I'm going to put the...
Shh.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Where's the snack in there?
Um, it might be in that one.
Because I'm going to put, um...
Because you heard she eat cookies.
Um, toppings and stuff on this normal...
Um, I'm going to put normal...
I'm going to put, um, sauces and stuff on, um, this...
What is that beefy meat on it?
Chunky bucket.
Do not drink.
That's got to be, like, four years old already.
If you're older than 25, it'll make you look 25.
It is 2000...
It is 2009.
Oh.
It'll make you look 25.
And if you're younger than 25, it'll still make you look 25.
Okay.
If it's not 52.
Let's melt this stuff.
Doing this recipe.
Okay.
It is a donut.
And I glazed the bottom with strawberry cream.
Awesome looking.
I'm going to put it on here.
And then I'm going to melt this on top of this.
Really cool.
Well, actually, I need another layer.
Are you going to use a...
Okay.
And bake.
Oh, I always...
This is a two-layer donut.
Okay.
With chocolate on top.
Where's those Reese's things?
Reese's.
Yeah.
Because I got to put those on top.
Here you go.
Do you want that...
Do you want the peanut butter or mint?
No, that's okay.
Okay.
I put the cookie on top of the two donuts.
And then the cookie melts.
If you put the chocolate...
The peanut butter chips in right, it melts through the chocolate.
All right.
Is this the right recipe for it?
No.
But I'm making it my way.
I love these chicken nuggets.
They have little faces on them.
That's so cute.
But that's shell.
Mom, these are sure good donuts.
Yeah.
Real good donuts.
Yeah, kids.
These are real good donuts.
I'm sure you're having some.
I'll see you next time.
I'm just like, do I want those?
You can show us how big these grandiose things are.
Oh wait wait, a cross answer cake.
Nunchucks.
What are nunchucks?
It's those little chain stickling things.
Watch out, here comes Baby Sammy.
He's coming right for the camera.
I guess that's the work that we're going to have to do.
I'm just trying to scare him off.
Not anymore.
Because I wouldn't want to scare Baby Sam, would I?
That's a kid size bowl.
Hey people.
Yes, I know.
Bakuna is probably running away.
rolling over in his grave right now.
I'll never come back. If he does, I'm gonna
rip my head off. Not really.
I'm that sure he's not gonna come back.
Because he's not.
The prophecies say so.
But there is
a new evil coming, but
it's gonna be about 20 years.
I don't know if I read that number right,
but at least I hope it did.
Yeah, she went with Almond and Sunflash.
She did? Yeah.
Where'd they go?
They went to this mountain right here.
That one? Yeah, the island where we took
this big picture. Cool.
They'll be able to see the moon.
Hey, there I am. Where are you?
Oh yeah, right there.
I'm right there.
Uh-huh.
And there's Dr. Schneuer.
There's Tahu and the Exocoa and
Optimus.
Along with the girls and boys.
Ruby, oh, he's at the shop getting worked on.
Oh, Giovanni is gone.
You know what happened? He actually took a crash
into a wall, and it
broke his left beam on the side.
Oh.
They had to repaint it and everything.
We forgot to give him
those...
I never made a pill yet that...
I mean, motor oil yet that, um...
keeps their...
Where's the big bowl?
That's good looking. One sister nut.
What do we got here? One sister nut.
Sandwich,
pie, one ice cream vanilla.
Oh, doesn't that look
scrumptious? It's cooked yet.
Wait a minute.
What was that?
This used to be a doughnut. This used to be a cake.
Um...
That used to be a...
That was a cookie cake.
That was another cookie cake.
And what was that?
That was my huge brownie.
And that, I don't want to know.
That was
the biggest pie I've ever made.
Unlimited machine. Unlimited earth.
Here's another one.
Hey kids, the muffins are done.
How long have they been in there?
I put them in yesterday. They're supposed to come for a day.
Alright kids, gather around
in a circle, because you know what time it is.
Story time!
You know, back in...
when we were preparing for the Universal War
and I was sending Godok?
Guess what?
Remember when I said we were taking a journey
to Mata Nui? We're not.
We're going to Lego Island for a vacation.
Yep, we are, little... That is so
rad.
Too bad Baby Moon Blaze won't be along with us.
Let's get these muffins and stuff up.
That's for treats for the kids who are extra good.
Yep.
And remember, the key word is...
Because...
You set the kids up and set the story up.
Um...
Oh, Baby Ellie, you lost your bunny ears.
Okay, get in order kids.
The King of Shorts is in there.
I'll look for the King of Shorts. You set them up.
Shorts, King of Shorts, where is it?
Let's find the King of Shorts.
We can't do it.
We found a squirrel to Baby Sam
and Baby Jess's delight.
And, um, got six steps of it,
because I have not told the story in a long, long time.
Well, we weren't here.
Step away, hurry up.
Don't forget this. Yeah, it's okay.
I don't think the kids care, do ya?
No, why did they get their story pack?
I found a pizza, just in case.
Isn't there, like, another pizza in there?
But I do need hair. Okay.
Okay, you ready to begin?
Okay, start up.
Um... This'll do.
Okay.
Extra big ears. Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Um, servants coming in.
Jamming bottoms.
Another chair.
And a dog.
Well, if you couldn't have
x-ray vision back,
x-ray vision...
And only
the King of Shorts survived.
It's over now.
Okay, back to the story.
Princess and then the stupid
two just fall down.
And they lived
good to die.
And we're just gonna take attendance here.
Okay, Baby Sunstripe.
Baby Constance.
It's the wrong voice for her.
Oh well. Baby Moon Grace?
Nope, she's not here.
Okay. Baby Sunshine.
Yep.
No, all the cars aren't here.
They're not? Okay.
I was imitating her.
Okay, Baby Matimia.
Here.
Baby Chocolate?
Yeah. Okay.
All the mice are here, so you don't have to do that.
Baby Sam?
Here.
Baby Death?
Baby Jess? Here.
Theresa? Pikachu?
No, they're not here.
Blossom? Here.
Definitely here.
I'm here.
Now, there's one thing we forgot that we do every morning.
It's time to play.
Pledge of Allegiance.
I don't have a chair to push in, so...
To the flag, kids.
Just pick one.
Yeah, just pick a flag.
Guys, do you remember
that we only pledge to the U.S.
since after the
AC was made?
So, we do their
pledge, remember?
Okay.
But it's not the United States.
Well, yeah, it is, because it's the flag of the United States.
We pledge allegiance to
the flag of the United States
of America, and to
the Republic for which it stands,
one nation, under God,
indivisible,
with liberty and justice for all.
Okay,
everybody, sit down.
Don't say wibberty, say liberty.
Can everybody say that?
Liberty!
Hey, there's Tahu's mask. Oh, yeah,
remember he left that there for you?
See it up on the wall?
Hey, it's not centered.
I'll fix it. You continue with your class.
Okay.
Time to get out.
Okay, let's begin school.
We spell babies wrong.
When you put the S and it has a Y,
you put I. Pick a number.
From one to ten.
Six.
Is it division or modification?
Division.
We'll find out the answer later, and then we'll add up all the answers.
Modification?
We're spelling it.
Oh, she went out to a restaurant with
Dr. Justin Yarby,
because they had to talk about the kids or something.
Hmm, hope they're saying good things
about his mighty little munchkins.
From one to ten. It can't be six or eight.
Or, take your time.
Sam. Eight, seven, that's
from one to ten. And that has to be
divided by six.
Oh, it's a hard one.
Blossom, what is it?
I think one.
Oh, she should know that.
Say it with more
I'm sure of it attitude.
I'm sure of it.
I'm going to sneak and I'm going to check you all,
all you guys.
Eight times eight.
Blossom, you have to know
this one.
You need to.
Here. Fourteen.
Minus nine.
Minus equals one.
No, it's actually negative eight.
Okay.
There's nine, there's nine birdies.
And then you take, and then nine of those
birdies fly away.
So there's no more birdies left.
So that's zero birdies. Get it?
For two trots.
Hey, Stacy. What's this thing that spins?
Do you know how they are sleeping?
That's going to know me all night.
What's that?
Oh yeah, it's time for us to go to bed.
Alright. Night, Stacy.
Is anybody going to sleep up?
Yeah, you carry them up.
Huh?
Yeah.
Okay.
Night, Stacy.
Who's that?
I don't know. Maybe there's a stray dog outside.
We'll check it out tomorrow.
Night.
Let's go check out where that dog was.
Can I go put my sweater or something on?
Come on, let's go.
We've only got a certain amount of time.
It's like five o'clock in the morning.
Four o'clock.
I should get a treat.
I'll meet you upstairs at the launch pad.
Okay. Me?
What if we find one?
I don't know. Try to trap it.
Let's go find that puppy.
Whoa, wait up, wait up.
Where are we going to go?
We can't run too fast because we might scare it.
Where did you see him?
I saw it around back there.
Let's go before he finds us.
This is a secret passageway.
I hope nobody...
Well, nobody's actually gone through here.
So,
we can just sneak through.
There's a car. Maybe they dropped him off.
Because they abandoned him.
Yeah, maybe they put him in one of those boxes.
Like some people do.
Crates?
Oh.
Those things.
I like this place. It's like a little sanctuary.
Um, let's go this way.
Maybe he's in there.
No, he couldn't be.
Let's go this way.
So, what are we going to do?
What are we going to do if we find him?
Probably keep it.
Where's that?
I didn't say we were going to keep it.
I'm just making sure the hideout's locked.
Good thing we didn't put bars over the window.
Okay.
Why?
I don't know.
It was just in it.
This way.
Hey, wait a minute.
I've never actually been back here.
Have you?
Yeah, once.
I've never been back here before.
What do you see?
Nothing.
Let's go.
Let's dive into this forest.
Come on.
The trees are so tall.
Okay.
And then you jump.
One, two.
Let's see what's up here.
Is it broke?
Looks broke.
Whoa, that's a freaking big forest.
The suction cups are on the wrong way.
What are those holes in the forest for?
See?
Three holes.
I say one, two, three, four.
Oh.
Sorry.
You better get down there and try to find that puppy quick.
This way.
Whoa.
Whoa, looks like we can ride up waterfalls.
Alright, we're going to jump.
This way.
Okay.
What?
Let's try to find that puppy.
Okay, let's head in through that forest.
Okay.
This way.
I know, there's a shark.
Whoa, what happened to this bush?
It's like all dead.
Okay.
What do we do?
I don't know.
Into the forest.
Stacey?
What?
I can't find you.
Whoa.
That was hard.
What?
What's that?
It's a puppy!
Stacey, did you get him?
Maybe somebody dropped him off here.
I don't know.
Look how scruffy he looks.
He must be so hungry he's chewing on that tree.
Come on, this way, Stacey.
Let's go back to the hideout.
Follow me.
I don't know if there's any addresses.
I didn't get a chance to look.
He was running so fast.
He got tangled in some bushes.
And then he got tricked a little.
Are you okay?
I ran into that light.
Okay.
You okay?
Yeah.
Okay, super heel.
Okay, that's better.
Look how fast he is.
Man, that's a fast dog.
This way.
We're gonna have to head through those bushes again.
To get home.
Okay, this way.
Let's head into the bushes.
I saw the tree.
The tree, yeah.
Come on, let's go.
Help, pull me up.
Is Shelby doing okay?
Okay, Stacey, let's head inside.
Come on, Shelby.
Okay, let's go inside.
Shelby?
No.
You're much bigger than the kids.
Yeah.
I think he's a full-sized dog.
What kind do you think he is?
Probably a Shelby.
Look at that face.
I checked out.
I think he's a boy.
Where should I put the kids?
I'm afraid they're gonna be scared of him.
That's okay.
Just leave him out.
Shelby, come here.
I don't know his name.
He looks pretty young.
He's bigger than the kids.
He's small, so...
Shelby!
I guess he could.
I'll put him away.
You can play with Shelby and keep him occupied.
That's okay.
We can get him some later, but I'm pretty sure he's eating because I felt his ribs and he's pretty...
He looks pretty muscular.
Mm-hmm.
I think he's more muscle than anything else.
That could be his cover.
Come on, let's look for a cover for you, little guy.
I'll get you a cute little hat for him.
I'll just stick it in the purse and...
Oh, the cover.
That's okay.
No.
I have a sense of humor, Stacy.
Now that we have a dog,
it's gonna be a little different down here.
Here's his little towel.
Come here, you little rotten rat.
No.
Can I put it on him?
You can try.
Doctor says.
Stylus or sweaters?
We'll just have to take it off when he has to go to the bathroom.
Because I think it's a little long.
Now sit.
You're gonna have to cooperate.
Put your middle paws in the sleeve.
The sweave?
In the sleeve.
I like talking.
No, you don't think he lost any of his baby teeth yet.
What? Look at the fur on his mouth.
He'd lose one.
Sit. Shelby sit.
Good boy. He knows his name.
And he looks pretty young.
He could be a messenger dog for how fast he is.
Can I send a letter?
No.
Let me see him.
Because he is a soccer mom.
So I guess life in the super family is gonna be a little different now.
It'll be a little more.
Do you want to give him a hundred dollar bill?
Oh, he looks so weird.
Walking like that.
Why?
Probably gonna eat it.
Do you think a hundred dollar bill would be this size?
Well, some are.
It says illegal tender.
Shelby!
Okay.
Let's get to bed for the night.
Hi everybody.
Where is he?
Just for our midday nap.
Because we were just outside, weren't we?
Why?
Probably gonna eat it.
Do you think a hundred dollar bill would be this size?
Well, some are.
It says illegal tender.
Why?
Probably gonna eat it.
Shelby!
Okay.
Let's get to bed for the night.
Good night everybody.
Where is he?
Just for our midday nap.
Because we were just outside, weren't we?
It's four o'clock in the morning.
Well, today's the day that we're leaving for the beach.
Stacy is at gymnastics.
Hmm, I'll have to pick her up then.
Okay, let's see.
I have my list here.
And I'll see what we have.
Okay, kids, check.
All the kids' toys, check.
Um, car, check.
Of course.
And drivers have our limousine,
or car, check.
We don't wanna
spoil our secret
of us because
who'd wanna drive a limousine
for a hundred miles?
We probably know who we are.
And that's the vehicle we're taking to the beach.
Okay.
I think that's
everything. Okay.
Let me just check for sure.
Oh, wait.
I think I'll just take one more
look around here since
I'm not gonna be back home for a while.
Ugh.
It's gonna be nice going to the beach.
I mean, yeah.
Lego Island.
It's gonna be awesome.
Barbecues, boat rides,
trips to the actual beach.
Oh, man.
Actually, I think we're staying
down there for a whole week.
Hm.
All right. Head up here.
Whoa.
Secret garden.
If I can meditate a little bit.
Okay.
Secret garden. Okay.
Secret garden.
Wonderful place to
stay and meditate.
Let's talk
to the old ancient tree.
Okay.
Well, see you guys
before we're about ready to go.
Um, see you later.
Here's our drivers.
Where's Shelby?
Okay, we're going to go pick up
Stacy and we'll be on our way to the beach.
And let's go back to
Side 2.
And here comes
Stacy.
Come on.
Hello, Stacy.
Back away, you beast.
Amanda, come on.
He's in the way.
Hi.
Um.
Okay.
Ready to go to the beach?
Just put him down for now.
They're our drivers.
They don't know us very much.
Okay.
What's your undercover name?
Um, I don't know.
Okay.
Ready to go to the beach?
We are on the road again.
How can we?
There's Shelby.
Shelby, Shelby, Shelby.
Aw, he's so cute.
Alright.
Now we are going back to
Tell me about your night.
Currently crossing the Bay Bridge
over Lake Naho
on the lakes.
It will soon be Lake Island.
How's it going, Stacy?
Good.
How long is this bridge?
I'm not sure.
But I know it's really long.
This bridge crosses
the largest ocean in the AC.
Stacy.
Hi.
It's like 910.
911.
What's he doing?
Art.
Ew.
This is like a flashlight I'm using.
What's in here? What's in there?
That's my arm.
I see fur.
Shelby, no bark.
Is that Cameron's face?
No.
I don't have a camera.
Here's a flashlight.
Okay, go get him.
Go get him.
No.
Again.
Shelby.
Hi.
We got here last night and we were sleeping
so we teleported you inside.
Did you sleep good last night?
Okay.
I think we're going to the beach real soon.
Oh yeah, definitely.
I have his puppy treats over here.
We have boarding people with us.
So...
Make it a little loud.
Hey Stacy.
We are going to the beach.
Okay, you ready?
Yep.
Aren't the kids in the house?
Yep, they didn't want to come.
Okay.
To the beach.
The beach.
Hey Stacy, did you lock the car?
Yep.
Okay.
Let's get moving.
Wait, where's your stuff?
Oh, the drivers took it.
Come on, let's go.
Are you okay?
I found a sidewalk.
This way.
Did the drivers take our stuff up to the beach?
Yeah.
Okay.
I haven't been to the beach in a while.
I'm pretty sure Lego Island got bigger
since the flood resided.
Huh?
Yeah.
Ah, the beach.
It would be a great advertisement.
Sure would.
Okay.
I wonder where our stuff is.
Um, it's over there.
It is?
See?
Yeah, it's right here.
It's in the bucket.
Yeah.
That's a big stick. Let's take it.
Cool.
Beach Hermit, Evil Sister.
Let's steal her clothes.
And then we can hide.
Ah! Get your clothes!
I'll take that stick.
Let me have it.
Here's some money.
So how's it going,
Evil Sister?
Are we disguised as beach hermits again?
We're trying to discover...
Well, you know what.
We're trying to figure out
where Duxner and Stacy are.
Yes, but why do we have to be disguised
as beach hermits?
Why not beach hermits?
It's in my plan. Shut up.
Why did Makutus drop us off here anyway?
I don't know.
I'm not cut out for this.
Looks like Makutus is stuck in Arkovia
at the end of
Portal of Chaos.
Ah, well.
Let's...
I need to get those Vahki
before the Super Family does.
And then we can
destroy them.
Last time Makutu...
Last time Evil tried to steal something from the Super Family,
they failed.
Come on.
Okay, let's go.
So what do you think of this stupid plan of Makutus?
Huh. Well, let's go.
I'm crunchy.
Okay, let's go.
Come on, let's go.
Why is Shelby tied up to the
satellite?
Come on, let's get him. Then we can take a walk
and try to figure out what's in that
forest over there.
Okay, we have Shelby.
Okay. You ready?
He likes gummy Kratta too.
Gummy crunchy
Kratta.
It's a special edition. They're green.
Come on, let's go.
Let's go.
That's fun.
He can't do
that. He doesn't have
movable gums like us.
Or whatever you want to call that.
Looks like there's a fire here.
What's that?
There's Indians!
Run!
There's Indians.
Where's Shelby leading us?
Let's get out of here. There's a large
infestation of mosquitoes.
Come on.
Seems like two days
ago that we just got to the beach. Actually,
it was two days ago.
This way. Which way should we go?
That way or
that way?
This place is very strange.
The residential district
has changed since our last
place in
uh, you know,
Lego Island.
How do you think it's changed?
I don't know.
Seems like there's more people.
Usually.
Whatever happened to the mountain park
in our mansion?
Uh-huh. Shelby.
Where are we going next, Stacey?
The boat.
I think we are.
All right.
Let's get dinner and everything.
Huh.
Well, let's go get dinner.
We going tubing?
Yep.
I think you guys can probably go double.
We can?
Oh, cool.
All right, we'll go slow and we'll see how
how it works and then you guys
will be out there together.
Okay.
Shelby.
Shelby has to sit this one out there.
All right. What if he went tubing
with us?
That would be fun.
Of course that would be funny to tape. Video tape.
Are you okay? Yeah.
Was that a good boat ride?
Yeah. Where's Shelby?
Oh, she's over there.
Huh.
Man, that was fun.
Too bad I couldn't come.
He went fast.
Nice boat.
How much is that to ride that?
$200?
I don't know.
$200 a ride?
Really nice boat.
Hey, what's that cliff over there?
That should be fine.
And there's a duck.
How do you know? Did you just name it now?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's get Shelby and check it out.
Pull me in.
Well, I could fly over, but
I don't want to scare these people.
Put it down, put it down.
Okay, let's get Shelby.
A little bit. A little bit.
Come on.
Put your hand through.
Okay.
Don't let that be good.
Give me your hand.
Come on, Shelby.
Shelby, Shelby, Shelby.
Do, do, do.
This seems like an old-age island.
Cool.
Rain's coming.
Look at those clouds.
Hey, Stacy.
Is this the only piece of civilization here?
Look.
This way.
Are we at Shelby Cliff yet?
Have you ever been down it?
Nope.
It's high tide. Everything messed up.
Nice view.
Come on, Shelby.
Where's the kids?
I don't know.
They're hiding under the bed, probably.
Leaving today?
I guess we are.
It's hard to believe, isn't it?
It's been like
three days.
It was a whole week. It was fun.
Yeah.
No, actually, we're leaving tomorrow.
Yeah? Yeah.
Oh.
Wait a minute.
Hey, you kids.
Where were you?
At the ball.
Why didn't you come along with us to the beach?
We went with, um...
Are you guys packed in the morning?
Except for us.
Yeah, except for you.
Yeah, we did.
We had a couple of new shoes.
I'm glad that you're not hyper.
You guys want to head out on the deck?
Shelby.
What are you doing, Shelby?
What is it with him and Tickle?
I don't want to leave him.
Wait a moment.
Why is he barking like that?
Shelby.
Expensive toy?
Just give me an old milk container.
What are you playing at?
Oh.
Stacy, what was your favorite part?
Me want chicken salad.
Here.
I don't know.
I actually like them both,
but Tickle's pretty good.
What did you bring home in the van?
What did you bring here in the van?
Um...
Do something?
Oh.
He's not going to jump off.
He likes jumping.
Oops.
Shelby, let's dance.
Come on, Shelby.
Like a frisbee.
What are you listening to?
Dancing, man.
What do I smell?
Corn.
I smell corn.
Let's go see who's eating the corn.
Who's eating the corn?
I hear munching.
Let's go see what it is.
Let's go see who's eating that corn.
Hey, there's a toy.
This way, Stacy.
It's a shortcut.
Okay.
Are you talking to me or Shelby?
Do the corn.
Yay!
Come on. There's nothing there.
Sure.
Come on, we're going.
We gotta figure out where Dr. Snore and Stacy are.
Okay.
Where are they? Do you know?
Nope.
I wonder if the super family's hiding
in there somewhere.
Around the tie.
Well, we can't be loafing around
the whole time.
Ooh.
Did you see any Baki around?
I mean,
that week is already up.
We're gonna have to hitch a ride on the super family's
van to get home.
If we wanna do anything
to the AC.
How are we gonna get on?
Actually, it's more like a bus.
Okay.
Wait a minute. I think I see Dr. Snore and Stacy.
Over there. Look.
Let's go get them.
That was an awesome dune ride we had.
Yeah. Can we do it next time?
Um.
What next time?
Do it.
At the beach?
Yeah.
Okay, but that'll be a while.
Wait a minute.
We have this stuff to stay for one more week.
Can we?
Yeah.
Look at the cool stick I found.
It was right there.
I wonder if all my
sunplash and baby moon glaze
are doing good.
Aren't they gonna come down?
Uh.
I don't know.
I thought they were.
Let's go check on what's going on up here.
Wait a minute.
Wait. What are all
the baby badgers' names?
There's so many now.
Oh yeah. Okay.
Melis, Sunstripe, Constance,
Sunstripe,
Sunstripe, no.
And Sunshine.
That's only five.
Yeah, there's five.
Except for Alma and Sunflash.
Yeah, there's
Isn't Sunshine coming
Sunshine coming down?
Sunshine's already
with us. Moon glaze is
with Alma and Sunflash.
Sunflash, Sunstripe, Sunshine.
Ooh.
Sun.
I know.
Look at this flower.
This is weird. What was that
Wait a minute. I see footprints there.
Look. I wonder who went up through there.
I wonder how they got through the gate.
Wait a minute.
There's a news flash on my cell phone
that says look out for the Vahki because
there's some
It says they might be
four-legged or two-legged.
And they carry two large staffs.
Okay, that's kind of creepy.
Camera lens.
I
I don't know. I don't have. Yeah, it might be.
Hmm.
Looks like a coffee cup holder.
Looks like a camera holder.
Whatever. Alright. Who's that?
I don't know.
Let's go back into that little cave you were in.
That's not like you, evil
sister. What the heck is
going on with that thing over there?
I don't know. We need to get those Vahki
they were just talking about on the news.
They'll be a perfect weapon.
The Vahki over here. Get him.
Where's the super family in this?
They're over here. We got them.
Every day.
Are you done yet?
Okay.
What's this say?
Adopt a beach.
The goal of the
I can't read.
The goal of the adopt a beach.
You can't read either. Come on.
Can you see just over here?
How come you keep coming back over here?
Uh oh.
Storm clouds.
Come on. This way.
We're going towards the storm clouds.
That's smart.
But I thought storms attracted Vahki.
I think they do.
Ow.
Sunglasses.
My sunglasses are cool.
Yours aren't.
Because they're bendy.
Yeah.
I wonder if any of them went
back in there. I saw something
move over there. Okay.
One's over here in this
end of the forest.
This looks typical.
But there's a steel thing
over there in the woods.
Do you see it?
It's like a metal stick.
Yep.
What do you think?
Looks like there's been a lot of storms.
There's a lot of trees and branches
breaking off.
Look over here. Whoa.
Do you think maybe the Vahki did that?
What? They put a Coca-Cola bottle
down there?
They took the color out of it.
Oh, wait a minute.
That's Coors Light.
Once again, as Kadok said,
don't drink, kids.
Why don't you want them to drink?
Drinking is bad and we're bad, so...
But still not
cool for me. And how'd you know
that Kadok did that?
I don't know. I'm not revealing
that. Can you go spying
without me? I don't know, but these
bugs keep attacking me.
See anything? What are
those? I don't know.
Hopefully they're Vahki.
Vahki eggs. Wait a minute.
Am I obsessed with Vahki? Yes.
Ow.
Moving on. You hit me in the
stomach. What is this pole doing
here? What does
ESM stand for?
Evil Sister Makuta.
Oh, wait.
Why would I? Evil Sister Evil Brother.
I like Makuta better.
What?
Fine. Makuta
was a good guy. He's the one who
helped me out with... A good
guy, you mean?
Is it just me or do these Vahki like soda
and beer and crap?
Maybe it was just people.
I don't know what they would be doing back there, but
it doesn't look like it's inhabited by anything.
Hey! A camera lens.
We already found that earlier.
No we didn't. What are you
thinking? Why
are you treating your sunglasses like bifocals?
There, that's better.
Looks like this fence used to be
way up there at one point.
I want to go up there and see if there's any
Vahki.
Are those electrified?
Yes, I saw them.
Trying to saw metal apart with wood.
It's not wood.
It isn't?
It's drift.
Alright, I'm going in.
Whoa.
That fence doesn't look like that the last time
I looked at it. Okay.
I'm going under. Let's go.
Hey Stacey, what's your plan?
Crash.
Do you want to watch? Sure.
Are you just starting this game? Yeah.
Well, I didn't just start.
I just want to play again.
Well, let's go.
Did you just get this game? Yep.
Looks like the wind's picking up. Yep.
Are we going miniature golfing?
Yep. Let's put Shelby in the scrape.
Okay, let's go ahead.
He's not allowed to come.
Come on!
Okay, let's get in the car.
Closed Sesame.
On the road again. I can't wait.
We're going to go golfing in Australia.
Hey, it's called golfing down under.
I'm getting you.
My old baby.
Four koala bumps.
You got what?
You're the one who lost.
But that was fun.
That was fun. Now where are we going?
French fries? Sure.
French fries. French fries.
French fries.
Stacy, we've been doing that for an hour. Shut up.
Okay.
It's not there yet.
A big building.
What do you want to do?
Do you remember what it was?
Was it that?
French fries. French fries. French fries.
French fries. French fries.
Alright, thanks.
What?
Is that your undercover name?
Big building.
Oh my gosh, jumbo crabs.
Oh my gosh.
Don't you like me?
Mushy.
My sister named Mushy.
And my brother named Mushy.
Mushy, Mushy, and Mushy.
New Halloween marshmallows.
They're orange.
They're black.
Orange and black flavored marshmallows.
People.
Their style is like
so 50 years ago.
I mean, the guys wearing pink,
the ladies wearing
green, and the
other guys wearing pink.
It's cold out there.
When did this start, like 20 minutes ago?
I don't know, like an hour ago.
Everything's soaked.
Including me.
Storm picking
up too cold.
Hey, Stacy, what you reading?
Uh, just, freak out,
it wasn't a rhyme.
It's not that exciting.
Here's the kids.
Well, poo, teddy bear
for the kids.
Teddy bear.
No, it's poo.
No, that's poo.
I'm sorry.
It's annoying.
Let's count the badgers.
One and a two and a three
and a four and a five.
And one and a two and a three
Wait a minute.
One, two, three, four, five.
One, two, three.
One, two, three,
four, five.
Wait a minute.
Who are you?
When did she get here?
She got here yesterday.
She just climbed in through the window.
Wasn't she with
Sunflash and Alma?
Where's Sunflash and Alma?
They both crashed.
Are they okay?
She says she doesn't know.
We'll have to find out.
Where's the ocean?
We need to get to the ocean.
Can you take us there, Dad?
I don't know.
Only the badgers are going.
Everybody else has nap time right now.
Don't worry.
We'll tell you all about it.
Why don't you read the kids a story?
Okay.
I wonder what happened.
I don't know.
I hope they're okay.
Crash.
Crash is a lot bigger than that.
Yeah.
Stacy, I'll meet you outside.
On the deck.
Okay.
What are we doing again?
We're looking for them.
Shelby.
Should I let him out?
Yeah, go ahead.
Shelby, what did you do?
He's got a big stick.
How's that job we're doing?
He got it in my eye.
So, evil sister, what was this, um,
what's this,
uh,
evil place you're talking about?
Well, there's a lot of other evil
people around here, but they're not that evil.
Like robbers and stuff.
We're not there yet.
And, well, you're around where it is.
And they told me it's very
secret. There's a certain password.
To open the door. And you have to have a certain potion.
Isn't it like a village of evil people?
Yes.
They said you have to either have a password
or a potion.
And...
You have both.
No, I don't have a potion. I lost it.
But I still have the password.
Hopefully it's just a password.
Yes. It's either one. You can use
either one.
Let's go.
Alright, let's head into the forest. Did you find it yet?
No. We've been walking for hours.
But look!
I found some sort of creature.
Wait a minute.
What's that?
You were right, evil sister.
Look at this. It's a whole
village of evil people.
And even the sign looks evil.
Look how bent it is.
Hemlock.
Well, where's our place?
It's over here.
Is it where that shining window is?
Yep.
Alright.
We're mates.
Great. What's this doing here?
And they have a dog.
What's this? It's like a bird bath.
They have a dog.
And they named it Shelby.
That's the dog that the
super family has.
So I don't think they're that evil.
But hey,
it's the only room that was open
so I got it.
Hopefully it's the most secretive.
Isn't that where we just came through?
We went in the circle.
No, we just came
through there.
This is very secretive.
There was trees
in front of this that you had to say a password
to get in.
But apparently somebody said the
password a couple minutes
earlier.
It's so swampy, too.
And those people,
they're kind of cheery.
This way.
Where's the entrance?
It's over here.
How come you were here
before me?
I looked inside
because you were asleep
so I came and checked it out.
No, wait a minute.
I thought you checked while you were
with Makuta.
Yes, and then I thought it might change
so I checked while you were asleep this morning.
What is that?
I hear a roaring.
Might be the air conditioning.
Alright, let's go inside.
See? They're cheery.
I don't know.
Welcome aboard.
Oh, nice place.
Oh, a toad. How evil.
Hmm.
This is their cheery,
disgusting, sickening dog.
Get away from me.
Please say the password.
Password.
Hey, cool. It opened.
Well, there's
these boulders jumping over each other.
And on
that, oh, the way
to our mansion, right?
Have a seat.
On our way. On the way to our mansion.
And then you have to jump over some spikes
while the boulder is still chasing you.
And then you have to jump over a pit
which one of the boulders might
fall into. It might not.
I don't know yet. And then you have to spin
this man-eating plant.
And then you have to jump over this
really tall spike with little spikes
on it. And this is all to defend our
mansion that we're making?
Yep. And then you have to
jump over... Which will keep the Super Family out
if they ever find out our secret.
And we'll make sure they don't.
Then you have to jump over
a smaller pit.
And then there's two boxes
to jump on. And then
there's a steel box, a crate,
and a bouncy steel box.
When you break the crate, then
you have to jump in between the two boxes
which the top one will be bouncing so that we are.
Then there's two TNTs
you have to jump over. And
you can butt
what they don't know is you have to
set them off because
there's a shark in another
pit and when you set the TNTs
off, that scares the shark away.
Or it kills it.
But anyway.
And then there's
this raging whirlwind
of death!
You have to go into it and then you're done.
And then
the next one,
there's this up and down-y platform
and then there's this lizard on another platform.
Then there's a box and then
some fire. You have to jump
when the fire's not there.
Box to box, box to box, TNT.
A whole
tower of boxes.
But what the super family doesn't
know is that there's
two TNTs in. So when they
blast
through it, it'll blow
some of the stuff up.
And they'll get hurt. And there's another box
up and down-y platform.
Another up and down-y platform. And there's
a still platform with a box on it.
Then there's a TNT, a box,
TNT, TNT, TNT.
And then a raging whirlwind
of death again. Isn't there another page?
Yes, there is a page.
Floaty platform.
And then there's another platform that goes
up and down.
With a key on it.
And then you go into another
platform that's still.
And then you put the key
in this humongous door.
And when the door goes up,
a rock
comes down and sets
a TNT off.
And you have to get off the island.
It sets a rock off.
I mean it sets the TNT off.
On
another platform.
And since you're standing at the door
waiting for it to explode, the door
is going to close. But really
it stays at one
and never explodes. So you'll get
squished from the door.
And then once you finally figure that out,
there's a bee's nest
on the next platform.
Doctor Senor
wouldn't be so scared.
And that's all I really have.
And here's a list of things
I would want in the room
of my mansion. A robot.
A remote that opens
up all my
drawers, doors, and closets.
A cave sized bed.
And I have
a picture of the car I want.
What are you doing?
My plan involves
stacks of boxes,
flaming torches
in front of floating platforms.
You have to set off these TNTs to open
to get out of the way.
And you have to jump back on the floating platform
above some water.
Another part involves
falling steel boxes.
And then that closes
a door. And TNTs closing
a door so you can't get the key.
And these.
Well.
I only have darlings.
Here's. Here's.
There's no nitros in any of our plans.
I don't know. Do you have to buy them?
I don't know.
I was thinking we could put a battle droid
in one of the levels. A destroyer
droid in one of the levels.
And. Oh.
Why are we going to get a destroyer droid?
The super family has them all. What about a battle droid?
We could make a battle droid.
But the super family has a whole
army of billions of them.
They get a squishy one.
Okay.
You scared me.
And then they're going to go into a room with
seven TNTs. I'm just going to use these two.
What did you just open?
TNTs. Is there something outside?
Something just ran out.
What was that?
Maybe it was a
ball rock.
Maybe it was something better.
What could it be?
It looked really small.
If we find it should we shrink?
The forms that we're shrinking into
are not yet complete. That's why we're shrinking.
So.
When I completely finish
them. Um. We'll be
full size. Like now.
We'll be cooler.
Alright. Let's go get that
thing.
I want to write down some stats.
Are we ready? Yeah.
Alright. Let's get
ready to
um. Transform.
Uh.
Okay.
I don't want
to do this.
I got it. Okay.
Get ready. I'm a girl.
Wait a minute.
We must have switched positions while we
transformed.
Shut up.
What the heck is that mask?
It's the mask of
immortality or living forever.
So that means as long as I
wear it I live forever.
As long as I wear it
it's a key word.
Now let's go
find those Vahki.
Do you have any idea where they could be?
No. Well how are we
going to get there? You know.
I can't walk very good.
I don't have a car. Neither do I.
I'll be right back.
Independence Day fireworks
for the super family.
Now. We'll see you
guys at the fireworks and we're going to see
the little celebration
on the
vacation. So.
Hi Stacey. Are you ready for the fireworks?
Yep.
Okay. To the car!
Dun dun dun dun
dun dun dun
dun dun dun dun
Wait a minute. That's old Christmas tree.
Windy day
at the beach. Yep.
Okay.
Then there's Shelby.
Very windy.
Now what are we out here for again?
Don't forget.
I don't know. We're just going out here because
it's windy. It feels good.
So this is the tunnel you were talking
about. Okay. Let's go.
Dun dun
dun dun dun dun
Windy windy windy.
What are you doing? I wouldn't go
up there if I were you.
What? There could be bees.
How are we going to get down then?
Whoa.
Big hole.
Yeah. I can't believe
I'm not sliding down.
I heard rumors that the evil
brother and evil sister are on the loose.
But
I'm pretty sure the evil sister is
escaped. But
how can the evil brother be okay?
I know. It's definitely
not true. I don't have any good
plans. Huh.
There's cars
running around up there.
Okay. Come on. Let's go.
Dun dun dun dun
dun dun dun. This way.
You look
little. I wonder where those
stairs lead to. I don't know.
Do you want to go see? Oh well, I'm not going to find out.
Probably the bridge.
Look. There's some sort
of passageway up here.
I don't know. I heard there's a big storm
coming and that might be it.
See? Does it look
very stormy?
Well, the wind's picking up
and that cloud looks dark.
How'd you know that?
Yeah. I heard the way it's going.
This way.
We can head down through here.
Shelby doesn't want that.
Look down there.
Yeah. I think
this one is going to come. Look over there.
It's like all one color.
This
side is stormy.
Oh well. Some kind of surfboard warning.
Let's head back up through here.
Okay. Here's a new
channel I found when we were walking back from that
other one. It's kind of off to the left
a little. Do you know the way
back home or are we lost?
Well, I know the way back home.
We can just walk.
Something in my shoe.
I must get it out.
That's better.
Okay. This is a
nice path. This is a long
path. I didn't know it was this long.
Hey, did you hear that
in this lab they're walking
they're working on
these prototype things. They're supposed to
replace the Bohrok.
They're called Vahki.
They're supposed to be police for the AC.
How many
are they going to make?
As many as they need. Like millions.
But they're working on
the six types right now.
There's sand shooting out of my
toes. Along with everything else
mechanical. You know, blue, white,
red,
black, green, brown.
Look, there's
sand shooting out of my toes.
Not good.
Looks like the water's all moving that way.
One way. Left.
The storm's probably going to be moving that way.
Looks okay.
It's getting kind of cold.
Okay.
This is like a desert beach.
Are you cold? Cold!
Okay.
It's like a desert beach.
There's like nothing here.
Except water and sand.
Evil sister, are you okay?
Was that a car?
There's like a dune forest
over there.
Follow me.
Doesn't look good. I think a storm
is coming.
Yes. It does look like a
storm is coming.
What's out there? A buoy.
I think that's a lighthouse.
Way out to there.
Why'd you have to spoil everything?
Ah, a mountain. Don't crush it.
It could be a cave.
Looks like a tide shield.
Whoa, I can't even hear the wind down here.
Well, this isn't very much protection.
I can stand up and...
Come on!
I say go this way.
Follow me.
A dog!
Do you know who you saw?
No. Follow me.
I don't know. We walked along the beach and then we lost where we were.
What is this?
That!
A log, apparently.
Either that or something
very, very disgusting.
And big. It's a log.
Okay.
Come on, we've got to hurry.
You're not driving.
Sorry.
Okay.
Shall we...
Go on a big boat ride, aren't we?
Yep.
I'm gonna go put the white jacket on you.
I think the third...
No, this is the second one we've had.
Second one.
Okay.
This one in there.
Why are you playing with the minnows?
Okay.
Shelby. Watch him.
Shelby, look at him looking at that.
Shelby has his life jacket on.
On the water again.
The baby eel took a chunk out of the fish.
Shelby.
What are you doing?
We're planning our...
Mansion.
What have you gotten down so far?
We've been at this for like forever.
It's a good thing we got back to the hideout.
Nothing.
Are you sure about that?
I can't think of anything.
Absolutely nothing.
HTML code.
Nothing. Nothing at all.
Nothing at all.
Period. Period. Period. Period.
Whew.
To be continued.
There.
I'll continue that in the future.
But.
This is what I have.
Our castle will be this.
Extremely useful.
Let me put it over here so I can check the back of it.
It's very useful.
Turn this off again.
We use all these lifts
to keep it running.
And nobody will be able to get to the top
of the crystal towers.
Stop that. I used that for our mousepad, you idiot.
I'm getting my plans.
Oh.
That has stopped though.
No. No. We just can't do that.
We couldn't get those Vahki the last time we shrank,
so we're gonna have to do it again.
Cause I thought I saw something
running around out there.
How are my mules?
While you're fighting.
They're purple.
And the shoes are purple and green, but...
No.
What are you doing?
My plan's back
in their folder.
This is my mousepad,
not your freaking folder.
I'm done with this plan.
Hopefully this will be done
before we set our plan into motion.
The Super Family's almost
done with their vacation.
It's like...
It's Friday now.
They're going to be going home on Sunday.
So, we've got to hurry and see if there's
Vahki down here before we actually leave forever.
And they're coming back
to this Lego island.
When I first started my plans here,
they're too immune to everything.
I'm never gonna get this done.
Blinkies? Blinkies!
Okay, what have you got for your plans?
I don't know.
That's what I'm trying to think.
Blinkies. Even though they're not blinking,
they help me think.
But they haven't
seemed to be blinking.
But they still help me think.
Should we go get them now?
We need servants.
There's nobody following us.
99.9% of the world is evil.
We're the only evil left.
99% of the world is evil.
But we're the only evil left.
That doesn't make any sense.
99.9% of the world
is good. I'm sorry.
We're the only evil left.
.99999999
Since there are
trillions of people.
What are your plans?
I'm reading.
You couldn't read the second one because it's HTML.
Our castle and our plan to
conquer the world like every other
evil person wants to do.
But we will do it first.
Why?
Well, the last time evil won something was the Universal War
and the Super Friendly beat Makuta anyway.
My job is to return evil
to the amount it used to be.
50-50.
Not 99.9999992
.11.
.0001.
What's with the darn
What am I doing?
Okay, um, what's with the
darn background music?
Okay, we've got
to hurry and get our-
What? I went to my room.
I just lost all that I was working on.
Take 10 deep cleansing breaths.
Get your fingers off.
What are you doing?
I don't know.
Come on, let's go.
Transform into
our other forms. Okay, here we go.
This is it, evil sister.
I almost got my new pink
shoes dirty.
This is how we unlock the Vahki.
And it's smoky.
Like a smoke stamp.
I wonder if there's something under it.
Look. When you touch these
it unlocks the Vahki.
Don't touch it yet.
Okay.
Let's touch a button.
All right.
What the?
I guard this shrine
and you can't
get near it.
You'll never unleash those
Vahki. What do you think
you can do? Go around your head and
keep, um, guarding
and we'll just quietly
My mask can mind
control. Maybe I'll turn him
into my pet. You!
Somebody's ferocious growl.
Whatever. You are my
pet. Now, I will
name you Nivok and you will be
under my control.
Pretty cool, eh,
Lash? What are you doing over
there? I mean, um,
I was
surprised. Surprised
me. Okay, now he's
my pet. He'll be in my
control and my pet. Oh no, you
can just be yourself. There, it's running
away. Wait a second. I'm gonna
take a nap. You want to take a nap?
Okay, back to the drama.
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
It's a button and it will unleash
the Vahki. Your
pet thingy is asleep.
What? Your pet thingy is asleep.
Nivok! Not
pet thingy.
Now that I have Nivok,
I have something to fight with.
Oh, now you have a pet that fights your own battles.
Hmm, clever.
Kind of like Makuta and I don't want
the Super Family saying that I use other people.
Makuta down due by
awakening these Vahki.
Press a button and
control them. You're
so not dramatic.
It's kind of boring.
I wonder what happens when I touch
these. I wonder where all the smoke comes
from, is coming from.
Smells pretty good. Maybe that shiny
thing.
Don't touch it, you fool.
I touch it, I get burnt, and then you
touch it. It made a weird sound.
They're pretty
stupid. Okay, now.
Why don't you go
be stupid somewhere else?
Okay.
Goodbye. Was I being stupid?
No! You don't touch it because I want them
all to be boys. If you touch one, then one
will turn into a girl.
We girls.
Let's see if I can switch things
around inside here. I want
a girl, at least one.
You are so stupid.
No, I'm not. You are.
Ow. Your hair is like
steel wire. My arm's
really creaky.
Creaking my arm. My arm's
popping now.
You are being extremely
stupid.
What? I had some coffee.
Why don't you jump in some. Hey, I never
thought of that. That kind of looks like a fusion reactor.
Da, da, da.
Could we cut down on the smoke a little bit?
Are you trying to talk to it?
What am I doing? I'll just press it.
They will all be boys. Yeah, that's why I don't
want you to be dramatic.
Okay, here we go.
No.
One of them's
a boy now. I'm going to touch
another one. One of them's going to be
a girl. Well, let's wait
and see if they appear.
Any minute.
Oh, yeah. Any minute now.
Any minute. Oh, I heard
a rumble. That might be
them coming.
I'm up. I'm up.
I'm up. I'm up. I'm up.
I'm looking for a
Vahki and a
clean pair of shorts.
Mm-hmm. Well, that's
lame. I'm
Vahki Vorzat. What do you
want from me?
What do you want from me? A clean
pair of shorts?
Because I think I peed myself. Are these
on right? Of course
they are. Mr. Smarty Pants?
Well, you're supposed to follow
us. I think not.
We are meant to be police.
Not evil, Father Wars. How did you know that I'm evil?
Because that's what we're programmed to do. We're supposed to replace the Borok.
And it's kind of obvious because I'm a mask. Duh.
Yes. Anyway, I can erase minds.
I like your attitude.
Get your gifts ready, Bordok.
Okay, okay, okay.
Don't rush me.
Well, it appears you're out of plans.
You should have.
Before they came and, you know, just took us out of our game.
Our objective? Terminate you.
Nice try.
Um, I don't know. Just take care of her. Like, throw her somewhere.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, yo, pink boot girl.
Yeah, um, go fetch yourself.
That was cheesy.
Ha!
It was cheesy, but easy.
Yeah, I should be a comedian.
My head.
Nevok!
Do-do-do-do.
What?
You have a Nevok Rahi?
Oh, yeah, I got him about, like, 20 minutes ago.
More like five.
Oh, I've always wondered where he goes.
I mean, uh, well, oh well, you know, cause...
Oh, well.
You'll never take me out.
Nevok, use your wings attack.
Ha, ha ha. I'm good at this.
Hurry, Nevok, use them.
Ow!
This way.
How come your disc is whiter than mine?
I almost fell there.
Okay.
Standing back up.
Don't you know I don't really have a neck?
Yes, we do. It's just extremely tiny.
Yeah, that's what I said.
I don't really have a neck.
My shins are blue, and my feet are gray. Is that bad?
No. I'm the same way, except I'm green instead of blue.
Okay, um, we don't really go together, and neither do Black and Red.
What's up with that?
I don't know. Now let's begin the fight.
I heard something.
Take them out. We don't want them starting evil plans.
I took the other one out. She's still trying to fetch herself.
If only I had the Mask of Shadows right now, then I could control you, make you evil.
But we're not programmed to be evil.
Yeah. Why are we programmed again?
I'm still the evil brother of Doctor Senor's enemy.
Doctor Senor?
Now I will take care of you.
That's fun.
Come on, Bordock. Let's fight.
I'm a pretty bad boy.
I'm a ballerina.
Evil sister, can you...
Sorry, she's told me to try and fetch myself, so I'm still fetching myself.
Vroom. Vroom. Vroom.
This is fun.
Tick-tock-tick-tock-tock-tock-tock-tock-tock-tock-tock-tock-tock-tock.
Well, that really leaves Strath.
You're kind of in the way.
Who, him?
Yes. You're in the way.
Oh, sorry about that.
Karate, um...
Kick.
Chop.
That was lame.
I just kicked his body up in the air.
What about his head?
Get my head back on my body.
Now, I've told you that once now.
That was lame.
I hate bees.
I'll chop them in half with my safety scissors.
Don't they look like safety scissors to you?
Yeah. What do mine look like?
What is he doing here?
What do mine look like?
Um...
Big Takanuva skin.
I have little hooks on the back of mine so I can do this.
Come on, itch.
Scratch.
Itch, itch, itch.
Ow, man.
Itch, itch, itch, itch.
Wait a minute.
I don't talk like that.
Who said, ow, man?
I do.
You bitch.
You gotta pay attention to yourself.
You thought he will become under my control and then I will have my first two and you
will be able to convince the other four to come over on the evil side.
Not yet.
Run.
Slow motion.
Let's get out of here.
They ran off.
Well, we've got to get down to that chamber and find more Vahki.
Evil sister?
Hello?
I'm back.
Did you fetch yourself?
Uh huh.
Good.
Now help me move this so I can get into that little hole and find more Vahki.
There.
Come on.
Okay.
You first.
That sounded weird.
Hello?
Is it safe down there?
Okay.
I'm coming down.
I'm gonna come down.
I can't fit so I'm gonna send my mask down and then it'll teleport me down there.
Okay.
Eh.
Doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo.
Don't get up, Botox.
That was me.
My vacation's over already.
I don't know.
I've got to pack the safe number.
Universe.
Universe and everything.
Yeah, I know.
Stupid.
Hi.
Well, hopefully there won't be anything to kill.
Yep.
So we can have more vacation at the house.
That would be great.
Yeah.
Two weeks of it.
Of vacationing at the beach.
I'm thirsty again.
I have no trouble finding the fairway.
I'm blind but I get butterflies like anyone else.
Oh.
I experience the same satisfaction and the same frustration.
I'm blind but my passion for the game is 2020.
I think winning the U.S. Amateur obviously meant a lot to me.
It was funny because I really didn't play well that week but I putted just tremendously well.
I made everything all week long and I think more than beating the guys I beat in the six
or seven matches it took to win, I think I frustrated them more than anything because
I pretty much got outplayed every day by every one of them but I just kept making putt after
putt after putt and eventually just kind of wore them down.
The familiar Stadler-Rye comic wit.
How about the sideburns?
That looks thicker than some of this Oakmont rough.
As we get back to this match, five holes to play, Wittenberg two down, a little bit of
an opportunity here, Ryan?
Well, I don't know about an opportunity.
You're playing at Mountain View.
Not a bad spot.
A pretty good line to rough, however, though.
Going to have to land it, I think, a little short of the hole and kind of let it release.
To get left, it should come left right off that knob right there.
But unfortunate.
Still a good shot.
It stopped right on top of that knob, Gary.
Okay, let's continue the discussion of the Flanagan choice of drive around this hole,
especially with a two-up lead.
Well, Roger, I almost have to wonder.
I mean, the guy's really only been playing competitive golf here for the last few years
at this, anywhere near this level, and certainly not that experienced.
Right now, with a two-up lead, make pars.
Just any way to make pars.
Force Wittenberg to make a birdie.
Well, absolutely.
If he pars all the holes that he's going to play today from here on out, he will win the
amateur, I believe.
We just haven't seen this golf course give up many birdies.
I don't think a player can come from behind making birdies.
I don't think that's likely to happen.
How about the tree?
Can he keep it under that all right?
Has he got plenty of room?
It is a factor.
It is something he's going to have to concern himself with.
He's going to have to keep the flight of the ball down.
Got a pretty good break.
Ball hit a golf cart up here and just a fucking little left.
Had it gone where it might have gone without hitting that cart, he would have been behind
the tree.
Come out with a lot of overspin.
Right up against the primary cut again.
Just made the second shot a lot more difficult than it needed to be.
What about the scene yesterday?
Talked about how Flanagan doesn't have many supporters here, but right after immediately
winning his semifinal match, got on his cell phone, talked to his mom at home, Connie,
and his older brother, Luke.
It was about 3 o'clock in the morning in Australia.
His father works as an electrician in a coal mine.
His dad, they call it the dog watch shift over in Australia, works from, leaves home
about 9 p.m., works through the night in the bottom of a coal mine.
His dad had no idea that his son earned a spot in the Masters, earned a spot in the
U.S. Open.
He was working his graveyard coal mine shift, which has helped finance Nick's amateur dreams.
It's been a rugged summer for Flanagan.
Came over here from Australia with two buddies.
They've done it very economically, sharing hotel rooms, sometimes sharing the beds, sometimes
sleeping on the floor, trying to gain experience and, as he says, play against the best competition
on the best courses.
He did.
He played with his caddie, Gary Whitehouse, during the break today.
He said he did talk to his father finally on the cell phone.
And obviously, dad was very excited to hear the news that his son has earned himself a
spot in the Masters.
Both finalists earned a berth in the U.S. Open and the Masters.
And then the winner of this match today also gets into the British Open.
So just some of the things that are at stake and some of the reasons why this championship
just turned your golf career upside down.
Pretty heady things for two teenagers to be thinking about.
And pretty heady things that a guy that just started playing the game five years ago is
going to be playing the Masters.
And you know what, Dan?
To be honest with you, I can't recall anyone who started and got into the Masters quicker
than that.
I mean, five years or so.
That is incredible.
Quick putt here, Roger.
Off this little knob in the middle of the green.
Extremely fast.
The ball stopped right on top of the knob.
You're right.
You were talking about Gary.
I don't think he could drop a ball there.
He didn't get to stay here.
This is critical.
Must get it down there where it's close.
Put the pressure back on Flanagan.
Come on.
One more.
Go.
All right, Wittenberg.
And don't forget, tonight at 7 o'clock Eastern Time and Pacific, the World Gymnastics Championship
concludes with the women's all-around finals.
Boy, what a job the U.S. women's gymnastics team has done to capture the first-ever world
team gold medal already.
Overcoming some illness and injury.
You can watch more at 7 Eastern Time and Pacific tonight.
Flanagan pulled this shot off many times throughout this championship.
That one's a little firm.
His technique is textbook, Dan.
You'll see the hands well ahead.
Just kind of pick the club up.
Lead with the hands ahead of the club face.
Don't worry so much about following through.
Always accelerating the club.
Not letting the grass control the club face.
I see him take some more deep breaths.
He said he got a lot better night's sleep last night.
Not great, but I'll tell you what, a lot better than the previous night when he knew that
Masters and U.S. Open berth was on the line.
He didn't sleep much at all.
Yeah, he remarked that he thought he was going to be a lot calmer today.
I wonder if that's the case right now when it's so close.
All right, he's got a putt here to retain his two-up lead.
This is the 32nd hole of this 36-hole run.
This is the 36-hole final.
After this hole, there are just four holes left.
And this little putt does have some movement to the left of it.
More to play.
Nick Flanagan moves closer to realizing a dream.
This used to be the deadline until Unisys Systems Integration bought the Wall Street
Journal valuable extra time because only the latest news.
Can you say you've reached an agreement?
Yes.
This is the real news.
Imagine it.
They've worked hard to get here.
Persistence, performance, strength.
It all paid off.
So how do achievers secure their future?
They do what more than half of the Fortune 500 do.
They put their confidence in the Pacific Life family of companies.
With over 130 years of experience and $350 billion in managed assets, secure your course
in life.
Rely on the strength of Fortune 500.
Buy in.
Derive funds.
choo-choo.
Paid for?
Stay a few years.
You never really see the market, get caught Fed, get caught a few bucks.
Only a few sales on the stock market survive off.
And when you have options, you keep yourNIEB.
I hope you enjoy this video.
live.
championship 36th hole final on a beautiful day here in pittsburgh hi everyone jimmy roberts and
it's probably safe to assume that this championship means an awful lot to both casey
wittenberg and to nick flanagan but they're not alone because there are others to whom
this championship means an awful lot even some who are no longer in the mix
steve flayden knows all about the attention big time sports can bring
as a georgia high school quarterback he turned down offers at notre dame and florida state to
play at duke when they were good he spent a year in the nfl and then everything changed when doctors
discovered he had a brain tumor the operation robbed him of 10 of the coordination on the left
side of his body that was 14 years ago since then golf has been how he competes and how he proves
himself he made it through qualifying into match play
you
and into the second round how much meaning do you think this universe has for him
for some it's not only this championship but this championship bob bugna has spent the week
caddying for george zaringer he was five years old when his dad topsy a steel worker and sometime
caddy got jack nicholas's bag at the 62 open bugna said his dad told him he had a chance to work for
someone else but that nobody wanted nicholas by the end of the week the
golden bear had the first of his 18 professional majors and topsy bugna was his son said the most
popular guy in town he bought a new car was flown to california to be on a tv show father eventually
talked son into caddying too which he has done here at oakmont for 23 years do you think companion
usga championships at oakmont 41 years apart for the bugna family might have a bit of meaning
but no one this week has been more a walking breathing example of what this
championship means than has tripped keeney in 1994 he made it to the final match had he won
the championship would have in fact been his way station en route to professional golf he had his
opponent six down early in the 36th hole final but well we all know what happened since then
he's watched his sister win two u.s amateur titles carried the bag for his brother while he won
another he was so serious about this week that he picked up his own shag
balls while practicing all the better to remember that every single one counts and when he finished
always the last one he hit had an oakmont logo but he lost in a second round upset
this is my shot this is my golf course um it's a perfect golf course for me it's a course that i
love and i'm gonna do everything i can to complete complete the keeney trilogy to win a united states
amateur and mid-amateur and uh it'll be the dream come true it's um the odds are astronomical but
i'm gonna give it my damn chance and i'm gonna do everything i can to complete complete the keeney
just to try to do it in a game which has become rich beyond imagination this minor solar system
has not only been around longer but will likely exist for as long as people play sometimes the
richest prize can't be measured in dollars it's one thing when golf is your job it's quite another
when it's your passion those are the stories thank you jimmy you unique to this championship
you just don't find them anywhere else gary no you really don't dan and uh which one uh has its
own special meaning to that individual no question about it by the way uh george zaringer fared uh
pretty well in this championship made it to the quarterfinals before losing and was uh just named
today as a part of the uh walker cup side that has uh been announced and mr zaringer will be
the oldest u.s walker cupper since uh 52 year old phil campbell back in 75 lee
williams
21 years old also a part of the walker cup team just announced today williams will be a redshirt
junior at auburn let's get back to this championship final at hand roger malpy out there
as flanagan uh clings to that two-up lead both players t shots here in good shape nick flanagan
just missed the fairway just in the fringe cut off the fairway and got a good lie casey wittenberg
down 100
yards to the whole hole cut on the front right portion of the green just eight paces and gary
these front pins on some of these holes are just so difficult to get close to you have to land the
ball short of the green now and be able to strike the ball properly but you have to guess a little
bit just where it all landed in order to get it close you do and it seems like roger so many of
the front hole locations are in areas where the greens are very severely sloped as well
this one just right of the of the pin uh you know the green rolls away and the green rolls away and
the green rolls away considerably you got to take it in a little left of the hole moving a little left
to right just right of the hole but i think you got it to shade heavy
part of uh 71 71 yardage total there the second longest to host a u.s amateur championship
flanagan on this monster par four checking out the wind with gary whitehouse
167 yards to the hole ball will hit below his feet as casey woodenburg and that will help move
the ball from left to right which is really the idyllic uh shot shape here oh much more in control
of his swing today than he was yesterday rhythm is much better transition from the top of the
swing coming down much calmer go ball hit very high just a little left of the hole
well two lands softly who comes up short
a little short game contest from there nick flanagan with four holes to play has the two of
lead over casey wittenberg the notion now but trust me i could be so now's not the time to give up on
me look you're the one who created me so you're the one who can do something with me because it's
not how many ideas you have it's how many you make happen accenture helps turn innovation into results
accenture is the proud sponsor of the accenture match play championship a world golf championships
event with capabilities that will amaze you both on road and off ford explorer is the most trusted
suv in america we took a wrong turn at greenland if you haven't looked at ford lately look again
let's say this is you yeah you're the king but being the king isn't always easy so
when you're with allstate you'll have over 50 000 professionals to help protect you
from claims adjusters who can help you fix a broken castle to emergency assistance to ride your rescue
to lawyers that go to court with you if you need them and your allstate agent who knows the moves
to help you helping you the king feel protected just one more way you're in good hands with allstate
golf isn't paneled lockers and carpeted dressing rooms it isn't titanium graphite or carbon steel
it isn't stately
two dirt clubhouses golf is about keeping your head down your left arm straight
and playing the ball as it lies and always remember you can never beat golf you can only
join it recent u.s amateur champions of course everybody knows
ricky barnes now and what he has done after earning his spots in the u.s open and the masters
especially oakland hills the site he won last year eastlake bubba dickerson the year before and great
sights and some uh
great champions there well david gossett matt kutcher winners now on the pga tour and keeney
has played his way onto the pga tour with some very good play this year in fact wittenberg plays
out of the uh tpc at south wind in memphis the same club as uh david gossett who won that amateur
title at double in 99. i think at first well short just a little bit of a pocket in there
that he had to put through and did not get it through it wittenberg in fact trying to become
uh the next uh big story golfing wise in memphis everyone knows that sean mckeel
won the pga championship in a spectacular fashion wittenberg commented uh earlier
this week that it's been like the super bowl in memphis with mckee winning and
perhaps wittenberg if he's able to pull this off will give memphis golf fans another reason to cheer
roger this uh coming up a little hill a little bit uh ever so slightly uh he has to put you that same time
of a pocket a low area but we'll come across the right side of it which i think will influence a
little bit left about midway through the putt i think it'll come back right at the end which it
does a good putt yeah should be a conceited car although we've seen a lot of short cuts not
conceited understandably so because of the uh speed of these green flickness of these greens
but that one given to casey so now flanagan with another one of those butts gary to uh
have the hole he has just not missed any of these and you just have to wonder can he continue to
keep making them roger the stroke uh very short very firm he's got wonderful touch he certainly
does i do like his stroke certainly for holding short putts he seems to be more effective in
around the hole his speed control from away from the wall hasn't been all that good but you get
him in this distance and
he doesn't miss many missed one there
short game magic out of steam at 15. it's a great time for wittenberg to cut into the lead three
holes to play and clannigan now just one up as they walk to the next hole let's uh get a little
more information from jimmy roberts on uh what you talked about in your piece earlier jimmy yeah
danny well uh we told you about bob bugna the caddy for george zaringer here this weekend that
his father was the caddy for jack mcconnell
nicklaus in the 62 open well after the open nicholas gave bugna all of the kind of artifacts
surrounding his wind gave him the cap the towel from his bag he gave him the bag tab and a number
of other things and bugna's bugna gave them to his son fred who is bob's brother and most recently
the bag tag which i believe we're seeing right now somebody offered it to fred bugna 40 000 on ebay
for the 1962 bag tag and he said no
he said no well he said he's thinking about it
so much history just being around the grounds here and talking to the members you find out these
uh little great little anecdotes stories and tidbits thanks for that jimmy great stuff well
what about 16 gary the long part long par 3 is right 235 yards today does play slightly downhill
hole location back right corner of this
sloping green this shot just a little left of the hole toward the center of the green let's take a
look at the swing of casey whitmer beautifully balanced setup position lets the club open
naturally not much lower body motion good full shoulder turn drives through up onto his left side
nice straight left leg beautiful balanced right shoulder closer to the target than the left very
much what i would call an example of the modern swing that we see so many of the youngsters use
that comeback trail again remember
for down after the morning
18 he has cut it to just one down that with the three iron to get this ball on the putting surface
this ball going at the left side of the green throwing at the left side
will it hold right up against the primary cut of rough again take a look at nick flanagan swing a
little bit different good setup a little bit different than what we see with casey wittenberg
fairly similar here big wide shoulder turn now as he comes through he hangs back on his right side a
little bit more and we see the bowed left left side swing it's
knee at impact. A little bit different position. A little handsier swing. Wittenberg was three
down in a first round match. Was four down at the turn in a third round match. Can he
do it again? MSNBC presents an extraordinary documentary. Join Forrest Sawyer for Thoroughbred
Stable to Stardom. Tonight's only on MSNBC.
NBC Tuesday, Dog-Eat-Dog is back. Two episodes of Dog-Eat-Dog, back-to-back. NBC Double
Dog Tuesday starts 8, 7 central.
Any way you want it, it's the Dollars a Day event. For a few dollars a day, your quality
plus Ford dealers are bringing you some of the best-selling vehicles in America. Get
Ford Focus for just $6 a day. Taurus for $7 a day. Escape for only $8 a day. F-Series
for $9 a day.
And Wingstar for just $10 a day. Never before have there been deals like this. But hurry,
the Dollars a Day event ends September 2nd. See your quality plus Ford dealer now.
Welcome to Safe Auto Insurance Company.
Well, there's always someone ready to take your call.
For immediate coverage, that's it. I can't do this anymore.
Uh, Mike, what's wrong?
Stop the music.
You know, the first thousand pounds was great, but I can't take this.
God, Mike, we're already running over budget.
No, Mike's right. I've...